I'M RIGHT, JUST BE CONSISTENT,
THE TEXAS WORM IN A PUBLIC
SAFETY, WE WANT TO GO TO
PETE RICKETTS RIGHT NOW, THE
NEBRASKA GOVERNOR.
THE COCHAIR OF THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION AND I WILL
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT SAME
SUBJECT HERE, THIS IS OF GREAT
INTEREST TO YOU.
BUT, WHAT IS INTERESTING IS THAT
IT ONLY SEEMS OF GREAT INTEREST
TO SOME OTHERS IN THESE AFFECTED
CITIES WHO ARE ONLY EIGHT NOW
WORRIED ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF
MIGRANTS THAT THEY IGNORED WHEN
THEY WERE JUST IN TEXAS, OR JUST
ON THE ARIZONA BORDER.
THEN IT WAS A NONISSUE.
AND NO ONE SAID A PEEP ABOUT IT.
NOW IT IS AT THEIR'S DOORSTEP,
AND THEY ARE DOING WAY MORE THAN
PEEPING ABOUT IT.
SOME ARE EVEN FILING CLAIMS OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO
PROTEST WHAT IS BEING DONE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> Pete: YES, YOUR PREVIOUS
GUESS WAS EXACTLY RIGHT, AND YOU
ARE RIGHT, THIS IS HYPOCRITICAL
BEHAVIOR.
AND AGAIN, IT IS JUST, HOW THIS
ISSUE ON THE SOUTHERN BORDERS
ARE AFFECTING ALL OF US THAT SO
MANY OF THESE OFFICIALS WANTED
TO IGNORE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, HERE IN
NEBRASKA, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN SINCE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS THE ABILITY TO
DEFEND OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IS
THE HUGE AMOUNT OF FAT NULL AND
ILLEGAL DRUGS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER AND WE HAD A YOUNG WOMANA
COUNTERFEIT PILL WITH THAT WAS
REPLACED WITH FENTANYL AND SHE
DIED OF AN OVERDOSE, AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS ALL TOO
COMMON A BIT EXPERIENCED NOW
WHERE WE SEE SO MUCH FENTANYL
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND
IT'S KILLING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
HERE IN STATES LIKE NEBRASKA.
>> Neil: I'M JUST WONDERING
WHERE THIS GOES I KNOW
GOVERNOR NEWTON REALLY WANTS TO
TAKE THIS CASE, AND HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT TO LOOK INTO HOW, YOU
KNOW, HOW THESE OTHER GOVERNORS,
SPECIFICALLY GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
AND FLORIDA, WITH A MARK THOSE
VINEYARDS THING AND OF COURSE
WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN TEXAS
WITH THESE BUSES GOING TO A LOT
OF THE SANCTUARY CITIES.
BUT, DID NOT SAY BOO ABOUT THE
MANY, MANY TIMES THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THROUGH ICE,
HAS DONE IT THE SAME AND MUCH,
MUCH GREATER NUMBERS WITH PLANES
THAT LEFT LITTLE NOTICE, MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT, YOU KNOW THE DRILL
BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
FOR ALL I KNOW NEBRASKA HAS.
SO, WHERE IS THE CONSISTENCY
HERE.
AND WHERE IS ANYTHING
APPROACHING SOLVING THE PROBLEM?
>> Pete: THERE IS NO
CONSISTENCY.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT WHEN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS FLYING
IF HE IS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY, THEY WERE
LANDING THEM AS YOU POINT OUT IN
THE MIDDLE THE NIGHT AND THEN
DENYING THAT THEY WERE EVEN
DOING IT.
YOU KNOW, OF COURSE, THAT RAISES
CONCERNS FOR MY COLLEAGUES LIKE
TIM REYNOLDS OR BILL LEE, THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND IT WAS ONLY UNDER DURESS, IT
SEEMED LIKE, THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY ADMITTED
THAT THEY WERE DOING THIS.
SO, THEY WERE TRYING TO COVER
THIS ALL UP AND FORCED MY
COLLEAGUES IN FLORIDA, TEXAS,
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS OUT IN
THE OPEN.
SO, I THINK THAT, THERE IS JUST
HYPOCRISY COMING WITHIN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT HOW THIS IS BEING HANDLED.
AGAIN, I THINK YOU HEARD FROM A
PREVIOUS GUEST.
THIS HAS BEEN A HUGE BURDEN ON
OUR BORDER TOWNS THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DONE.
AND OF COURSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS A HUNDRED
PERCENT WRONG WHEN THEY SAY
THEY'RE DOING MORE THAN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
POLICIES THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PUT IN PLACE
BROUGHT ILLEGAL CROSSING TO A 40
YEAR LOW.
A 40 YEAR LOW.
AND HERE YOU CANNOT EVEN GET THE
PRESS SECRETARY TO SAY, HEY,
PEOPLE DO NOT EVEN COME HERE
ILLEGALLY, DON'T BREAK OUR LAWS
AND IN FACT IT IS DANGEROUS TO
DO SO, WE CAN EVEN GET THEM TO
SAY THAT.
>> Neil: IT'S EVEN WORSE THAN
THAT, GOVERNOR, BECAUSE THE
READING IS THAT THERE IS NO
READING, THERE IS NO PROBLEM
DOWN THE BOOK, THE BORDER